check out so let me let me let me show
you this post here from uh bbc world
service check this out why china's zero
coveted policy and shanghai's strict
lockdown is in everybody's interest
according to epidemiologist dr eric ding
oh yeah i know uh no thank you no
remember what i said at the beginning of
the show yeah what was that well just
that there are a lot of people in
america and in the west who are
completely comfortable with these kind
of tactics to eliminate covet zero code
is disturbing man you can't zero the flu
i don't know why they're trying to zero
covid yeah it's here to stay as far as i
can tell it's what we've been told yeah
and well then the question is are they
trying to zero cover let me you know let
me just say to the point this this is uh
this bbc story i guess it's like it's
like a podcast so i'm not gonna play
their podcast but uh this dr eric ding
guy saying it's in everybody's interest
i hope that's out of context i i
sincerely hope what he means is
specifically for china and not for us
because if the reference if the idea is
we here in the united states should be
locked in our homes for a week and told
we cannot leave for any reason and we
will not be given food
well americans i think would act quite a
bit differently than the chinese you
know you think yeah second amendment
yeah people won't silently starve to
death here
in the cities
i think in the cities they would do as
they're told
i think out in the country people are
going to be like depends on the
neighborhood cities they're going to be
getting the hell out of their apartments
and coming out to the country to see
where all the people have the resources
and that's where you're going to have
the problems yeah right there starving
migrants well yeah but people eat hungry
desperate people leaving cities going
out to where there is resources so yeah
what happens when that happens yeah like
so this is something
so this is this is the question then
what we see in china is horrifying
people screaming out their balconies the
drones saying control your souls you
know urge for freedom or whatever if
people in big cities if it does come to
the point where you know what did joe
biden call it a global famine if the
food shortages do get that bad if the
food inflation is as bad as people think
it is and it's bad if it's if it's as
bad as people think it is
are these city people gonna run to the
country because the question becomes
second amendment
if if i've got chickens and i do chicken
city chicken citylive.com and someone
comes and they're hungry
you're not touching my animals because
we we have these animals we cultivate
livestock so that we can survive
if someone comes and thinks i'm going to
steal that well people out in the
country are going to be like i got to
defend my property my friends and my
family you can't just let anybody come
and steal your stuff
what happens yes do they do they load up
do they
do people start fighting right
yeah well i just want to say this the
sort of the the city urban liberal types
the dumb yuppies they'll just sort of be
sitting ducks they'll stay in their
apartment when they're told to these
aren't independent thinkers but when
you're looking at the neighborhoods with
high crime rates where people do uh you
know own guns or at least the criminals
own guns and there's more of a gang
presence they will absolutely start
moving out into more rural areas and
search for food and you'll see some
ugliness if we ever get to a point where
there is massive food inflation that's
starving people so let me ask real quick
uh chicago mm-hmm
what city uh hoca falls yeah where where
did you go up john amarillo texas so
what what what is that like is that is
that big city urban skyscraper if it
wasn't for i-40 there would be no
amarillo texas
especially if you look at the state of
texas let's go to the panhandle in the
top it's right in the dead center so
it's as flat as a board it's tornado
alley
it's the grain belt how many people oh
there's a couple hundred thousand
thousand all right so it's a decent
sized town but uh not how big is that
akron's big well i was actually from
chicago falls a suburb there's only 50
000 people yeah
but you grew up in a major metro no no i
never grew up in akron it was a suburb
of the of a minor map how far away from
akron
25 minutes 25 minutes and how many we
never went i went to akron like once
every three weeks this is called the
akron metropolitan area yeah yeah yeah
you got it you gotta nitpick me i'm just
looking at that point it felt like a
small town town was so small they didn't
even have a barber you see
that's how small
i'm just asking something
uh being from texas i wouldn't call it a
small town or anything like that but i'm
curious what your thoughts are on just
second amendment people defending their
property well what you're talking about
is not defending your property at that
point what you're talking about is
defending your survival of your family
and of yourself it's no longer hey those
chickens if somebody stole those
chickens or took my chickens or whatever
we're not in a famine it's not as big of
a deal but if i'm dependent on that or
whatever else i have for my kids and my
wife and my parents and whoever's around
me to survive then it's not a question
because then if you take my stuff we die
so it becomes a the stakes go all the
way to the top when you start talking
about famine water is the other thing i
mean you know people forget that
electricity is what makes the water move
through the pipes into your apartment or
into your house unless you got a well
electricity makes water move electricity
makes natural gas move electricity makes
fuel come up from the gas stations it's
a lot more than just your light bulbs it
makes literally everything move so to me
you know the electric grid and some of
these things we hear about somebody is
going to hack the electric grid or
whatever that is
honestly in my opinion is the most kill
shot you could ever put yeah you were
talking about solar sure yeah earlier
like the best thing you could get or one
of the best things a solar generator
yeah i ran across uh uh some solar
generators and i thought ah that they
probably suck you know i'm like ah i
thought well i'll buy the small one and
see how it does so i buy this little
shoulder generator a thousand watt
generator and it charged up pretty fast
and went okay let's see what it does i
said i wonder how long it'll run a
freezer
because i got one of those big freezers
it's full of meat and this and that i
wonder how long i'd run a freezer plug
that sucker in it ran that freezer for
16 hours wow which you don't even need
to run a freezer for 16 hours to keep
everything fresh you're saying you do it
eight and then leave it off for 16 and
then yeah just don't open it very often
you know so there are ways to get around
it but people need to think about it
right now yeah so uh there's this funny
hit piece on you know me and a bunch of
other uh you know trump pro trump
personalities from 2020 like where are
they now and they're like tim poole is
selling emergency food
and then i'm just like well it's kind of
crazy the mentality among the left is
that it's an insult
to to want to have emergency supplies
because i'm just thinking like if you
think
it's like a point of shame like i would
be in ashamed of telling people like
make sure you get some emergency
supplies i'm not telling people to set
up a bunker underground with 30 years
30 years worth of beans or anything i
mean like you get one of these buckets
put your clouds you forget about it i
also think you should have a first aid
kit i think you should have some water i
think you should download a survival
guide onto your phone but man when i
when when we have these conversations
about people in big cities being like oh
they're so dumb you bought emergency
supplies i'm like i don't want to be
anywhere near that city if it really
does get bad and the funny thing is i'm
not even prepper level
the preppers are sitting on their
bunkers you know smoking their cigars
laughing at everybody else because they
got nothing to worry about and really
the question is if you were a prepper if
you built a bunker
if you bought a bunch of guns if you've
got stored food you know how to start a
fire and hunt animals are you stressed
by this lifestyle is there something
wrong with that lifestyle sure you might
believe crazy things like the end is
nigh if you're one of these caricatures
yeah but really if you're if you're
somebody who lives out in a rural area
and you know how to survive you take
care of yourself i'm sure you're living
your best life imagine a more suicidally
stupid cultural attitude than it's dumb
to prepare for potentially going wrong
right and let's laugh at the guy who's
trying to build his ark before the rain
starts well i mean you don't have to
believe that the entire world is going
to end you don't have you don't even
have to believe there's going to be
societal collapse but how are you going
to sit here and tell me it's a worse
world if people have emergency food
stores but isn't that the story of the
ark yeah they laughed at it they laughed
at them i'm not saying that we're going
to be seeing anything of that magnitude
right and of course you have to make
that perfectly clear uh because they'll
clip you and go look they're saying
because people should have emergency
food they think the world's going to
flood also global warming is going to
flood the world guys take that very
seriously um but that's a good one too
yeah exactly
exactly um and so it's it's absurd i
mean even if there isn't some cataclysm
is it totally unthinkable that there
might be a situation where you need a
couple weeks worth of food
that's actually a really good point like
they're they mock the idea of emergency
food
yet they're the ones claiming the great
flood is coming yeah that the ocean's
gonna rise by 20 to 100 feet yep where
you know and then barack obama buys
beachfront property it's so strange
because they have paranoid fantasies
that would put the most ardent prepper
to shame about how we only have three
months to reverse global warming or
we're all to die and they say this every
three months or so uh and then they turn
around and go look at this guy's trying
to sell emergency food what an idiot
what would you need that this is
actually a really good point yeah i
don't i don't see conservative
emergencies of like there's you know a
survivor company or whatever and they're
selling all this stuff like be a rugged
man and make sure you can survive in the
wilderness i don't see any of these
companies saying global warming will
wipe us all out you need to because
certainly that's a path towards selling
your product right they should you know
we should do i'm gonna do this i'm going
to create a liberal prepper company yeah
i'm going to market only to new york
chicago and la and be like global
warming's coming man are you going to
survive the flood here's your inflatable
i'm going to sell plans for building an
arc edible inflatable rafts a wooden ark
here's how you build it so this this
goes way back why do why do city people
and i know all city people aren't the
same but let's be cliche for a second
why do big city people
mock and make fun of country people why
do they do that i think the reason is
because they look at the country people
and they realize that those country
people can self sustain they can defend
themselves they can grow their own food
they are tight they're a tight knit unit
they could probably get through a hell
of a lot more than you could get through
and they're threatened by it in a in a
way they're the alphas that are out in
the country they're the real alphas the
ones that are in the cities that dep
that are up in a skyscraper apartment
complex they they're the ultimate betas
because they're at the mercy of anything
that comes their way that's not right
but the ones out in the woods
they're gonna be all right for a long
time i think they're threatened by it
and they don't understand it because
nobody ever taught them
how to actually take care of themselves
i know this is a recent thing in america
that people don't know how to take care
of themselves don't know how to grow
food don't know how to defend themselves
this is fairly recent you know the way i
think about it is
how long ago was it where a father
was armed everywhere he went and if he
was with his family he was ready to
fight for his survival like a wild
animal how like you know you go back a
couple hundred years cities are
substantially smaller you look at uh the
revolutionary period there's only i
think two million americans within the
thirteen colonies fighting for
independence 2 million across the
entirety of the eastern seaboard so if
you're a family man and you've got your
your homestead or whatever
there's wild animals everywhere so when
you go out you're armed and you're
probably wearing thicker leather of some
sort you're not just walking around in
short shorts and a t-shirt with
sunglasses on because everything's safe
and fine
we we are when you when you compare a
couple hundred years ago today it is the
epitome of good times make weak men but
over a several hundred year period and
now
you know we we talk about what would the
founding fathers think if they were if
they came here today and saw the
government it's like well aside from the
fact they'd probably freak out what
happened with the government they're
going to look at people and be like you
walk around in short charts some people
walk like women walk around the bikinis
and they're going to be like
there's animals there's predators
there's there's there's bandits
robbers and you nobody cares about any
threats or danger and we can brag and be
like we've mostly done away with so much
of this through advancement technology
we're safe we have fat homeless people
and they'd probably be like wow
until they see
any potential disaster coming ahead
until they see these people are
completely unprepared for any kind of
survival although maybe they'll just
come back and eat big bowls of ice cream
and be like this is great
yeah
we should hope not and i wouldn't think
so but
it is very bizarre how we've been sold
this
idea that the best possible way to live
is to move as far away from your family
as you can to live in a small box next
to a bunch of other small boxes full of
people to not have a yard to not have
space and to not have children to just
perpetually consume for the rest of your
life without ever
orienting any of that consumption
towards preparing for whatever might go
wrong i think it's pre-internet
mentality stupid it's because when i was
in the city i would when i thought of
people that lived in the country i
thought of a lack of ambition that was
what i associated with and because but
now that's i don't know just the way i
grew up northeast ohio kind of small
town my aunts and uncles were hillbilly
we all went out to the country or the
other farm hung out you know
apparently it feels nothing better than
squishing your barefoot through cow
patties you know come up through your
toes
uh they told me but now with the
internet you just stick your finger in a
cow's mouth yeah i still haven't done it
yet but i'm going and uh alex jones
confirmed that does actually feel good
but then once the
once the internet appeared it changed
everything you can run a business from
the middle of a farm in arkansas um and
also
i don't know i think just realism is
start to set in for me you know cities
are super dangerous decentralized power
grid it's like we were rolling the dice
every day and i hope i don't roll a one
because if i do and the power goes out
and if the power goes out for six weeks
i have no backup plan and i hope the
roads aren't jammed so i can get out of
the city well this is this is this is
the crazy thing about emergency supplies
is i just tell people sometimes it rains
you know we saw this big huge flood and
i think it was in houston i'm not sure
where people were trapped in their
houses you never know what you're going
to need did you did you have emergency
raft how many of you had inflatable
emergency wraps now if i told you buy an
emergency raft you'd be like what why
crazy sometimes there are floods do you
live in a flood plain have you checked
maybe you don't but if you do you might
want to have an inflatable raft you can
if you don't need it your neighbor might
right your neighbor might need it this
is the strange irony in cities everyone
is packed on top of each other and yet
there's virtually no community and this
is the question you have to ask yourself
if inflation gets really bad if as biden
promised there are going to be food
shortages do you want to have neighbors
who know who you are and care about you
or do you want to be another face
another name someone that they have no
responsibility to once they're hungry
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you